here's a real story about a real patient
of mine details obviously change to
protect their privacy but it's about a
woman's pain that was consistently
discounted and blamed on her weight on
her gender unfair reasons this case is
also Illuminating many of the problems
that exist within our Health Care system
so I'm going to leave you off with three
actionable steps that you can take to
improve your health care relationship
with your doctor let's get started
Becky is a 58 year old female that has a
good relationship with the health care
System she has a primary doctor she has
an urgent care center near her home that
she frequents and in general considers
herself to be quite healthy over the
last few months Becky started
experiencing more joint pains and more
fatigue so Becky made an appointment to
see her primary care doctor in going in
for the visit the primary care doctor
asked some questions conducted a
thorough physical exam and came up with
a plan but the plan followed the
assessment and the assessment was that
Becky being a 58 year old female was in
her post-menopausal State meaning that
she has went through menopause is
experiencing hormonal changes also
happens to have a BMI of 29 which puts
her into the overweight category
therefore the doctor's conclusion was
Becky being slightly overweight having
this hormonal change due to being
post-menopausal is experiencing these
joint aches and fatigue due to that not
an actual medical condition that can be
treated with a specific medication
surgery or therapy so the doctor's
recommendation was to lose weight to
focus on herself to do some reading
meditation mindfulness all things that I
think most people would see as positive
in general so Becky being a good patient
went home started this plan tried to
motivate herself to lose a few pounds to
take some time away from work and go on
walks it wasn't until two weeks after
that initial visit when Becky woke up
and she could barely get out of bed she
was experiencing excruciating pain in
her shoulders in her biceps in her hips
in her low back it was so debilitating
that she did not want to get out of bed
and even go to work for a person to
experience that level of pain and
discomfort who was worrying to her in
fact Becky's husband urged her to call
9-1-1 and said maybe you're having a
stroke but Becky said you know what
let's call our doctor and see what's
available doctor says they're
unavailable for today but recommends
that she head on to her local Urgent
Care so Becky goes to her local Urgent
Care Center they take a thorough history
they perform a physical and they don't
quite know what's going on so they order
a bunch of blood work and Becky is not
privy to what blood work was ordered but
they told her to take some
anti-inflammatories in the meantime
until they get the results of that blood
work so they gave her a Toradol
injection which is a non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory medication similar to
ibuprofen or naproxen but because it's
given intramuscularly it works a little
bit quicker patients feel like it's a
little bit more of a potent medication
so Becky got this injection she felt a
little bit better she went home even
though she was still in pain she wanted
to be a good patient plus she had the
little voice in Her Ear of the previous
doctor saying this could be related to
your weight she didn't lose the weight
that she thought she could she didn't
follow all the mindfulness practices
that she set out to and she started
blaming herself which unfortunately a
lot of patients do in situations like
this three short days later she receives
a call from the Urgent Care and they
tell her that her blood work has come
back and they found that her
inflammatory markers were elevated ESR
and CRP these are non-specific
inflammatory markers so by testing them
we don't make a diagnosis of any
specific condition for us as doctors if
we see that we start feeling a suspicion
of an autoimmune condition where their
own body attacks itself or perhaps a
cancerous process or even an infectious
process in some cases she was very
worried about this potential diagnosis
she did have some family history of
cancer and when Becky came in they told
her that look there aren't sure exactly
what's going on but they believe that
given her joint pain was still there
that she would benefit from a seven day
course of Prednisone which is a steroid
that is targeting the inflammation
within the body so they gave her seven
day course of Prednisone she went home
started taking it what do you know the
next morning she wakes up feels like a
million bucks if she thinks it's solved
she feels great day two feels great day
three feels great and so on it goes the
rest of the week she's very happy and
she thinks her problem has been solved
but then comes day 10 when she is now
three days without the steroid and the
pain comes back so Becky trying to be a
good patient calls the Urgent Care makes
an appointment they see her and they
explain that they're not sure what's
going on and that they like for her to
see a rheumatologist which is a
specialist in joint health and
autoimmune diseases and they give her a
referral Becky again good patient goes
home instantly calls tries to make an
appointment and given this is March 2023
they give her an appointment for
December 2023. nine months so Becky is
sitting there in tears wondering why she
has to wait nine months while she's in
pain not able to perform life duties
take care of her home her family go to
work and just be even somewhat pain-free
so she starts panicking she starts
getting really worried and she
understands that she has to do something
else this is where Becky comes into my
office I saw a very concerned patient a
patient that was given the runaround no
explanation for blood test results I got
a sense that she was probably treated
unfairly given the fact that she was
carrying some extra weight and the fact
that she was post-menopausal and I have
to make a note here that if a doctor
says it would be helpful to for you to
lose weight because your joints are
experiencing a heavier burden than if
you were to lose weight that is good
advice in many instances but if there
are just jumping to that conclusion
without fully examining you fully
understanding what's wrong with you
doing a thorough evaluation
then they may be giving you a
misdiagnosis simply due to laziness I
needed to make sure and do the due
diligence and check where the correct
blood tests ordered were they correctly
interpreted because honestly when you're
going to an urgent care and you're
having multiple doctors take a look at
you and there's no continuity it's very
easy for things to slip between the
cracks for things to not get explained
or to even get thoroughly logged so I
requested all the previous lab work that
was done in all of these visits and I
found that it was in fact High
inflammatory markers the ESR and CRP
were elevated something else that was
interestingly elevated was something
called Ana testing which is anti-nuclear
antibody testing that we do to come to a
diagnosis of an autoimmune condition but
a a testing on its own is not definitive
it doesn't help us understand what
autoimmune condition is present so I
needed to really start from scratch and
reorder almost all of the lab work with
the exception of things that they've
definitely tested and figure out what
exactly is going on so I reordered all
this lab work I explained to her that
she's no longer going to get the run
around I'm going to be on top of this I
did all the labs and what did I find out
it was lupus it wasn't because she was
post-menopausal having hormonal changes
it wasn't because she was slightly
overweight and carrying that burden on
her joints these were misdiagnoses and
lupus was a missed diagnosis not just
her inflammatory markers not just her
Ana but other tests that really signify
that a patient is experiencing lupus
were also elevated like the
double-stranded DNA antibody there's
actually a scoring system that we use
from the American College of
Rheumatology that gives scores to
certain symptoms that a patient is
having plus points for having certain
tests flag positive on their results and
when I added up her points she fell into
the category of definitive positive for
Lupus I decided to get her Rheumatology
appointment as well she calls gets an
appointment for January 2024 these wait
times are just astronomical so I called
the office and I explained the patient's
pain her situation the fact that she's
in fear that she's going to be in pain
for the rest of her life and we're able
to speed up her appointment to just a
week and a half two weeks time I called
her back I explained everything that was
going on why I was ordering certain
tests what what the results showed me
why I want the rheumatologist the
patient was very grateful just that
conversation lowered her pain and that's
not a placebo effect this is a human
survival effect because when we are
nervous we are scared we are in a high
anxiety state the body turns up its
sensory response so by having the
conversation calming down her anxiety
we're able to help her pain with the
conversation alone since then she's had
an appointment with the rheumatologist
the rheumatologist put her on the
correct medication she's doing great
couldn't be happier and we're able to
help this patient out but what does that
mean to you the three takeaways I want
to give you from a case like this is all
stemming from what you can do to make
the encounter better and look doctors
need to do better the Health Care System
needs to do better but I want to arm you
with some very useful skills the first
is when a doctor gives you a plan
whether it's to take a medication a
surgery anything they need to give you
at least a working diagnosis they don't
give you that you need to ask you need
to ask them to document that working
diagnosis if they don't know what's
going on they should have even a list of
potential diagnoses to share with you
second ask doctors why they're sending
you to a specialist so that a you're not
wasting your time B you're not wasting
your money and C you can formulate good
questions in a plan when you actually go
see The Specialist and three this should
be common sense but it's an easy
question to miss when you're sitting
with the doctor and the doctor is
telling you here's the plan here's what
you do never forget to ask the question
what if it doesn't get better how long
should I wait if it doesn't get better
and what red flag symptoms should I be
aware of those questions will save your
life and if not saving your life they'll
at least make your life a lot easier
when you know the plan you know what to
look out for you're less anxious you
feel less symptoms
House MD says it's never lupus in this
case it was lupus but click here to
watch some really hilarious takedowns of
house empty that I did click here check
that out as always stay happy and
healthy
foreign